نتحدث عن الوضع في اصلاحيه سالتقي احد
الاشخاص من اللاجئين السوريين الذي كان
هنا في اصلاحيه وفقد عددا من افراد عائلته
ساتعرف عليه بدايه
اسف مصطفى خطيب
من محافظه ادلب
بوقت الزلزاله مسار الزلزال انت كنت
بالبيت كنت برا البيت خارج البيت انا
وابني اسمعني في اتجاه البيت
عن اربع طوابع
ي باماكن كثيره
فيها
الام وبناتها
ورحنا طلعنا خطرنا نسمع صوته من بعيد تقول
انه ماده اول بدء الثاني والثالثه
وضلت بنت طيبه والام
ثلاث بناتي الله يرحمهم
في اربع خمس ساعات
انا وابني وابن اخته
ما في عمليه طوارئ ما حدا ساعدكم لا
توقف نحكي كذا ما ترد علينا
وبعد ما طلعناهم ضلوا على الرصيف ست ساعات
وكمان جينا نشيلهم باسعاف او بطبيعه
الطوارئ ما يوقفه عشان سياره مدنيه شو
السبب يعني كان في ضغط ولا هو ضغط فيه بس
يعني في ناس موته مبينه يعني هنروح عم
بيدوروا على الناس ليطالعون نحن مطالعنا
وخلصنا بس وصلونا على المشفى
بعد ست ساعات شو عملتوا نقلت
تعازين الحاره
وعنده
والجرحى والمراه والبنت بالمشفى عنتاب صار
له من يوم الزلزله هلا يعني اركب لعندي نص
اللي عندي
ما بيجيكم
مساعدات بدبر حاله
ولا سوريا
حضرتك